Salut je crois que ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait de mentalisme, du moins un tour de mentalisme sur cette chaîne,
et c'est ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui, mais attention à la fin de cette vidéo j'ai une annonce pas piquée des hannetons
comme dirait monsieur Amixem je pense que c'est la plus grosse annonce que j'ai jamais faite sur cette chaîne
alors je compte sur vous pour aller la voir. Si vous ne regardez pas la vidéo en entier au moins aller voir la fin quoi ! Bref environ
une fois par mois je vais recevoir un youtubeur, une youtubeuse ou quelqu'un que j'aime bien ici dans ce petit local
et là cette semaine on envoie du lourd avec monsieur Avner. La vidéo que vous allez voir elle s'est passée en deux, temps dans un
premier temps, il m'a demandé de faire quelque chose qui a filmé lui,  pour mettre sur sa chaîne et m'a dit est ce que tu
es capable de faire si ça ça... je fais "Ok... je sais pas je vais essayer..!"
Et bien, j'ai bien galéré ! Alors maintenant qu'est ce qu'il va se passer ?!
"Bah écoutez bien, moi je vais vous le dire!" [imite Sarko]  Il va se passer que je vous laisse tout de suite avec la vidéo et on se retrouve à la fin.
On vient de tourner une vidéo sur sa chaîne on fait un truc de mentalisme, je cherche à retrouver un prénom
à qui il pense et qui était cette personne pour lui, et au temps vous dire que j'ai galéré !
Si tu veux me voir me planter
vas voir je te mets un lien dans la description.
- Si tu veux voir un mec supérieurement intelligent va voir dans la description,  c'est ça !
- C'est Avner
- Non je fais le prétentieux, je fais le prétentieux.
Non vous verrez,
- J'ai assez galéré quand même !
- T'as galéré mais c'est parce que j'étais fait galéré!
- Ouais mais bon même...
parfois on essaie de me faire galéré et on y arrive pas ! Enfin bref vous allez comprendre maintenant, pourquoi je suis un peu plus fragile maintenant,
il ya un petit côté PLS qui reste comme ca... On va faire un truc en deux temps
quelque chose sur lequel vous allez pouvoir essayer de participer si vous voulez et...
et quelque chose
que vous pourrez aussi essayer mais qui sera un peu plus compliqué. Je vais te faire choisir un mot alors ça c'est un bouquin que j'ai eu dans
le train l'autre jours à la Rochelle
mais il a le mérite d'avoir des mots dedans
"La veuve noire"
-Ah oui je connais.
Tu prends un mot dedans
n'importe quoi. Prends un mot quand même, qui à un peu d'intérêt pas un mot trop court comme "bien", "le", "la", "les",
prends on va dire au moins trois syllabes que ce soit intéressant.
Moi je vais même sortir comme ça il n'y aura pas d'ambiguïté.
- C'est bon.
- Et une fois que c'est fait tu l'écris sur un des trois papiers d'accord c'est bon t'en à un ? C'est vrai ?! Wouaw !
Un mot un peu long et tout ?
-Ouais.
-Cool ! Mais au moins voilà au moins trois syllabes quoi disons...
-Ouais ouais ouais.
-Comme che-mi-née.
Oh bé c'était tellement rapide ! [étonné]
Ok on peut être sûr que j'ai rien lu comme ça ! [rires]
Je vais sortir, je sors dehors ou là bas où je me mets là dans un coin ce que tu veux tu vois pour...
- je veux juste que tu te retournes
- Okay ça marche tu l'écris.
- Je t'aide un peu parce que tu as galéré tout à l'heure c'est pour ça.
- Tu l'écris sur un des papiers mais tu écris aussi un mot qui n'a rien à voir
genre "raté" ou "c'est pas ça" sur les autres papiers tu vois comme ça à la fin des trois papiers au moins un truc d'écrit.
- Ca marche.
- Ok.
Le temps que tu fais ça je me mets un coussin sur la tête
Je m'humilie.
Je parle et je chante en même temps !
Ok alors vous allez forcément avoir une coupe dans la vidéo ce serait trop long sinon mais
rassurez vous je suis resté comme ça il y a pas eu de...
- Il n'a pas bouger, il n'a point bouger je le confirme.
- Est-ce que tu peux les mettre en ligne tous les trois s'il te plaît vous allez essayer de participer aussi à ça en même temps,
avec la coupe vous n'avez pas forcément pu voir
sur quoi Avner avait marqué son mot
- Même moi je sais plu donc...
- C'est vrai ?
-Parce qu'il faut que tu saches.
- Attends
- Vérifie si tu veux
- C'est bon
- C'est bon ok ça finit de mélanger un petit peu.
Maintenant je vais te poser des questions
et moi à l'oreille je vais essayer d'avoir la bonne réponse et vous vous allez essayer de le faire mais en plus vous avez comme
avantage de voir Avner.
Est-ce que...
tu peux me dire la phrase suivante très sincèrement...
-D'accord
- "J'ai écrit mon mot sur le triangle"
- Est-ce que tu peux faire pareil avec le cercle ?
- "J'ai écrit mon mot sur le cercle."
-Ok est ce que tu peux faire pareil avec les vagues ?
- "J'ai écrit mon mot sur les vagues."
- Ok.
Est-ce que tu peux me dire dans quel ordre ils sont là les trois papiers de gauche à droite ?
- Triangle, cercle, vagues.
- Est-ce que tu peux me le redire mais maintenant dans le sens inverse donc vague etc..
- Vagues, tu voulais la phrase ou... ?
- Non non tu me les cites dans l'ordre
- Ah donc: vagues, cercle, triangle
-Ok.
Je pense que tu as écrit ton mot sur les vagues !
Est-ce que c'est correct?
- C'est ça bravo !
- Oui ok.
Ca c'était plus simple pour moi
- Ca va aller t'inquiète pas
- Tu as vu ça me redonne de la confiance mon gars !
Je vais te demander s'il te plaît de me mentir pour l'instant
en me disant la première lettre mais tu ne dis pas la vraie première lettre.
Tu dis une autre.
- C'est le L.
Okay. Est-ce que tu peux faire une phrase complète: "La première lettre est le L" ?
- "La première lettre est le L."
-D'accord.
Alors là je vais en avoir besoin mais c'est la seule fois je te demanderai c'est c'est vraiment pour
pouvoir calibrer tes mensonges et tes vérités. Maintenant tu vas me dire la première lettre est le et tu dis la vraie lettre
La première lettre est le S.
- Ok et redit encore avec un mensonge
-  La première lettre est le S... L pardon
La première lettre est le L.
- Je vais essayer d'avoir la lettre suivante
Mais ce coup ci c'est toi qui vas dire l'alphabet le plus vite possible. Tu dis A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H etc...
- a b c d e f g h i j k l m n o p q r s t u v w x y z
- Ok ça a déconné vers U donc ça veut dire la lettre était passé. C'est T c'est ça?
[rire d'Avner*]
Oui !
- Put**n
- Put**n je suis de retour les mecs je vous le dis !
- M'en suis rendu compte put**n, j'ai buggué sur T put**n !
- Oh la revanche du tigre !
- Bravo, bravo, bravo !
Ok après 2 consonnes il y a forcément 1 voyelle.
tu vas me dire A, E, I, O, U, Y.
- a, e, i, o, u, y
- Encore une fois.
- U
- Ouais [rire]
- Oui ok !
On refait un coup toutes les lettres de l'alphabet et tu penses à la lettre suivante
- a b c d e f g h i j k l m n o... p q
- [Rire de Fabien] Mais c'est le P !
- Put**n mais tu sais quoi mec
- Ouais
- C'est ça mais j'ai voulu te tromper en beuguant avant et j'ai pas réussi. [rires]
- euh...
Du coup je vais dire...
je fonce après en stock reading sur la fin
stupéfiant, stupéfiante ou stupéfaction
- Tu as lu le livre?
- Oui j'ai lu le livre.
- Voilà c'est ça.
Bravo
- Stupéfiant ?
- Te
- Stupéfiante.
- Bon ça va c'est...
- Stupéfiante !
- Franchement là c'est cool.
- Du coup sur les vagues.
- Put**n j'ai failli te tromper.
- Ah il a écrit en petit !
- Au moins je ne me suis retourné, comme ça par transparence je ne pouvais pas voir.
Nous avions aussi "sucettes",
- Je sais pas pourquoi je me suis dit qu'il y allait avoir un truc
- Et "surprises"
- un truc avec les S peut être ou...
- Ecoute moi je me dis, surprises, sucettes et stupéfiante
J'ai envie de te dire on en sait beaucoup plus sur toi maintenant.
[rires]
Super ce mec me fait flipper.
Merci mec
- Non mais franchement
là tu vois sur la dernière sur le P
je ne sais pas comment tu fais c'est là où tu fais du contrôle je pense
c'est que tu sais que maintenant je vais vouloir
- Exactement
- Et que je vais vouloir le faire avant
- Oui c'est ça à partir de la 3ème, 4ème lettres on va essayer de m'avoir
- On va essayer de l'avoir et en fait c'est... vraiment chapeau parce que là c'est très fort.
C'est génial, j'ai adoré !
- Alors là, l'idée c'était vraiment de faire un double format où vous pouviez essayer de faire les choses en même temps
en, en voyant plus que moi
si je genre d'idée vous plait vous le dites dans les commentaires comme ça j'en ferai d'autres
un peu construit de la même manière et si ça vous a plu surtout on n'oublie pas,
on mets des petits like !
[avec accent du sud] Je ne sais toujours pas pourquoi je prends différent accent à chaque fois
Je vous invite également à checker la chaîne de notre pote Avner
si vous voulez voir en même temps la vidéo
de mon demi fail
c'est plutôt rigolo !
Et je vous met évidemment le lien dans la description
"Alors c'est quoi cette grande annonce qu'il nous a soulé pour rester jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo ?"
Non c'est une vraie bête d'annonce !
C'est un peu l'annonce de l'univers pour moi dans ma tête.
Depuis le mois de mars je travaille sur un projet secret !
"Les projets secret de Fabien"
Un truc qui me motive de ouf.
Mais je ne savais pas si j'étais capable de le mettre en place ou pas
Ça a un rapport avec le monde du spectacle
Pour que vous puissiez comprendre l'ampleur de la chose j'ai commencé le théâtre à Paris en 2011
dans un café théatre qui s'appelle "les 3 bornes",
un petit café théatre de 49 places dans le 11ème
et quand j'ai fait ça j'étais en auto production
c'est à dire que je me gère tout seul,
j'ai pas de producteur qui s'occupe de moi, de chose comme ça
et là on est 6 ans plus tard
et toujours en auto production
Je viens de caler
une date de mon spectacle, de mon nouveau spectacle
tout seul en entier
Dans un petit lieu parisien
qui s'appelle l'Olympia !
Et rien que de le dire j'ai un feu d'artifice là dedans
Alors voilà, c'est rien de le dire mais c'est beaucoup d'excitation
et beaucoup de stress en même temps,
puisque comme c'est une auto production, je prends tous les risques
j'ai signé le contrat, j'ai loué l'Olympia et je vais faire mon spectacle là bas.
Reste à savoir quand !
Vous voulez la date
Et  bien la date c'est dans un an jour pour jour
C'est le 22 septembre 2018.
Alors ça parait loin,
mais c'est juste ce qu'il faut pour bien préparer correctement la date
et aussi pour voir si vous serez au rdv
est ce qu'on en fait une, est ce qu'on en fait 2, est ce que je suis obligé d'annuler parce qu'il n'y a personne
j'en sais rien !
Je ne sais rien du tout de comment ça va se passer, ça va dépendre de vous
Je vais également vous faire découvrir la nouvelle affiche
Il faut savoir qu'au moment où je tourne cette vidéo
elle n'est pas encore finie, donc... vous allez la voir là... je ne peux pas vous la commenter
voilà parce que moi je ne l'ai pas encore vu.
Et dans ce spectacle il y a beaucoup de singularité.
La singularité, déjà, c'est vous.
C'est parce que vous êtes capable de faire des choses de dingues avec votre cerveau et vous allez en prendre conscience durant le spectacle
vous allez vous auto étonner
J'espère bien que je prendrai le temps de vous bluffer en même temps
Ça dure à peu près 1H40
et c'est sur la forme d'un spectacle d'humour comme tous les spectacles que j'ai fait jusqu'à ce jour.
J'ai des premières parties de malade mental
Je suis ravi, il ne manque plus que vous
Vous avez les liens de réservations et tout ça dans la descriptions
N'hésitez pas à le faire au plus tôt
C'est ce qui permettra aussi de voir ce qu'on peut faire encore en plus autour de tout ça
C'est un kif, c'est un stress et... et maintenant
j'ai hâte de voir ce que vous allez en faire et j’espère que l'idée vous plait
et que ça vous fera plaisir que l'on puisse se retrouver
dans cette grande salle à Paris.
Voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire. Je suis un petit peu ému.
Alors je vous laisse là. A très bientôt.
Ciao !
Alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux aussi t'abonner à la chaîne simplement.
en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois, voilà juste ici. c'est ce petit rond là.
Ça marche depuis la tablette, le téléphone c'est extrêmement pratique.
Il n'y a plus de raisons d'attendre !
Allez y abonnez vous !
C'est cool !